it's time for a special what is it july
4th edition of scene and unseen for that
we turn to fox news contributor raymond
arroyo all right raymond you took to the
streets to ask people
whether they took pride in our great
country yeah and we kind of asked it in
a sneaky way which i like to do i ask
new yorkers how they're celebrating
independence day and what it means to
them the answers were startling and they
give us some insight into how people
really feel about the country
how are you celebrating um i'm gonna
celebrate the ideal of america and not
the actual country as it is oh what
don't you like about the actual country
you understand the whole the racism and
sexism and everything i believe the
ideal is a lot better than the actual
country the american dream can be
achieved in in my personal opinion but
we are not there yet
i am celebrating my independence as an
individual to get a paycheck on july 4th
you're not proud of the kind of probably
going to be working am i not proud of
the country are you proud of the country
i am i don't have too much pride for the
country because i feel like if i held a
lot of pride in my heart for my country
my fellow countrymen i'd be ashamed
quite frequently based off of the
conditions that i see in the street and
around me on a daily basis are you
celebrating
um no i'm black i celebrate juneteen so
that's that's i've never i mean it's
never been a big holiday for me and my
family i don't think there's much to
celebrate this year
i mean if we want to stay current with
it you don't feel independent and free
no absolutely not as a woman no
happy birthday america i want to see the
family you know what i'm saying getting
live with the homies you know i'm saying
go to take a walk you know what i'm
saying with your favorite uncle you feel
me and just having a good time bro just
celebrating life you feel me i just know
i want some some hot dogs and some
cheeseburgers you look like that fourth
of july
it makes me want to have a hot dog real
bad
as long as we got hot dogs cheeseburgers
oh yeah so it'll be a family event
you know what's disturbing how many
people dislike the country
these are citizens that actually hate
their own country even the celebrations
are kind of just get-togethers there and
when you look at this new fox news poll
judging whether you're proud of your
country or not the poll revealed
republicans 36 percent are proud of
their country 60 percent are not
that's a lower number than democrats i'm
sorry i don't who are these republicans
who aren't proud of this country i don't
care what you're political oh that makes
me mad that makes god the political
fortunes of the moment should not judge
or in any way prejudice your love or
pride of country that's your future and
your heritage and you should defend it
look it's no wonder some people are down
in the country they've been taught this
by republicans and democrats
my family never celebrated july 4th
and it was met with like so much shock
and it was because
you know my father was a student of
history they knew what they were doing
these republican members of congress
knew what they were doing and they need
to be shamed for it in the very least
they have co-opted this term patriot
to
to mean something that is
really just bastardize the term patriot
that's not what a patriot is patriots
don't do this
laura division is not a virtue and and
trying to separate people rather than
unite them that's what people should be
doing in the media and every day it's
running down not only a
portion of the citizenry but the country
itself this is really dangerous and
people don't stop to think about it
enough but when i was out interviewing
people we constructed a little
historical quiz i'll see if you can get
these
who established the celebration of july
4th and said we should celebrate with
fireworks and uh celebrations coast to
coast do you remember i don't actually
because i think it's been changing
everyone has a different opinion of it
probably the woman is probably martha
washington yeah i'm gonna guess um
martha i stopped history class when i uh
left school so yeah
school is out for the year not doing any
more questions can i phone a friend yes
you can phone a friend okay dope um can
i phone you
i'm gonna go with the wild card martha
washington
because
i'm not giving anything away who was it
john adams
she got it right
you'd leave it to the bostonian to know
you're the only one all day
this celebrity is a direct descendant of
someone who signed the declaration of
independence is it denzel washington amy
adams or reese witherspoon
amy adams i'll do amy adams when you
have power people will always try to
take it from you always let's just go
with reese witherspoon
reese with this one
hello patriots oh my god it's capital
barbie
damn i'm gonna have to go with him on
this one because i wouldn't know either
bro
you got it
john witherspoon is her aunt and um
she's a descendant of john witherspoon
who is the only clergyman to sign the
declaration of independence laura now
how are you celebrating
i'm going to be with my children okay
and we're going to be
somewhere oh my goodness look you are a
star-spangled girl right now you are our
fourth of july i'm glad we can celebrate
i wish we could put a historical
panorama right there in the dress yeah
could we have one well now you have a
historical pattern that is so disturbing
okay that is disturbing i i don't know
you're
go to break okay raymond's telling me i
gotta rap okay rap sam says all right
thank you raymond i'm exploding here hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else